[تصفيق]
اهلا وسهلا ايه الاخبار عاملين ايه في
الاول خالص كنت حابب اسالكم كان سؤال كده
وتجاوب علي
اول حاجه مين هنا خسر ماتش قبل كده
طيب
مين هنا خسر ماتش فيفا مثلا
بتحسه كان فاضل لي جون وخلاص بدخله واكسب
يبقى احساس رخم جدا طيب
تعال نخش دي شويه
مين هنا خسر شخص
سواء قطع معه بطل يتكلم معه او لا قدر
الله اتوفى
زي ما احنا شايفين في
ده معناه ايه ان احنا كبشر ويقال ديفاين
لوس
سواء بقى كان في عملي فاعمل ايمانبر
كلنا بشر كلنا مختلفين
طيب تعال احكي لكم حكايه كده
واحد صاحبي اعرفهم كان في سته ابتدائي
ولد جميل عنده ام واب بيحبوه جدا
بابايا حرام كان كل شويه بيتعب
وجت له فتره يخش المستشفى يطلع المستشفى
يخش يطلع يخش موال
خلص الابتدائيه وسافر ينبسط
اقل من 24 ساعه
جدته جالها مكالمه من مامته الو
ايوه يا حبيبتي ايه
خلاص خلاص ماشي مع السلامه
الجده جت وقالت للولد لم حاجتك بسرعه من
غير كلام
الولد ما فهمش في ايه
الولد رجع وفي باله 500 حاجه مش عارف يفكر
في ايه
الولد رجع نام وصحي لو مامته واقفه قدامهم
ونهاره سلام في
مامته قالت له باباك اتوفى
ايه
طلع ان الاب كان عنده سرطان في الكبد
كولين كانسر خلاص
تعالوا نتكلم عن الولد ده شويه تعالوا
نتكلم ازاي
عندنا اسمها
معناها ايه ان لو جالك اي حاجه تفرحك
حاجه تزعلك ازعل
انا في ايديا كوبايه ميه حطيت ميه حطيت
حطيت لحد الاخر ايه اللي هيحصل لما املاها
تاني هتطلق
هيحصل
تعالوا ندي مثال للبشر احنا احنا عندنا
حاجه اسمها البطل نفس الحاجه زي الازازه
المياه العاديه
مثلا انا جالي حاجه تزعلي
حاجات تضايقني هخزن اخزن خزن خزن خزن لحد
هنا فوق
يجي حاجه صغيره جدا تضايق الواحد
انهيار زعيم صريخ
دي فايده ان احنا نفضي الايموشن البطل كل
شويه نحاول نفضي اي حاجه تضايقنا ما نقعدش
نخزن جوانا
تاني طول هي اكسبريسنج
حاول تدور على شخص انت بتثق فيه ترتاح
معاه في الكلام سواء بقى كان او اكلوس
لما تلاقي نفسك قاعد تتكلم مع الشخص ده كل
شويه تلاقي نفسك قادر تتكلم معاه بقى في
اي حاجه سواء بقى يومك رحت سفريه حلوه رحت
حفله اتكلم عن
كده
هتلاقي نفسك ان انت قادر بدل ما تتكلم مع
ناس قريبه بس هتقدر تتكلم مع اي حد في اي
مكان بكل سهوله
تالت طول اسمها
لو انت شخص حاسس ان انت مش قادر تعبر عن
نفسك ممكن تختار
ممكن ترسم اللي انت حاسه تغنيه تكتب شعر
اي حاجه تخليك حاسس ان انت شايفها فيزيبل
قدامك سواء بقى على ورقه او على ورقه نقطه
اي حاجه
كده ممكن نقدر نلخص اول فريت ويلز ان ثري
اكس بس
رابع طوله عندنا اسمها سلفا
معناها ان انت قادر تفهم كل حاجه او تفهم
مشاعرك يعني افرح لما افرح صح مش بالظبط
بين سالب
انت تطلعها انت تخزنها
في طرق كتير قوي ممكن الواحد يكون سلفه
مثلا ممكن تجيب
تقعد تكتب فيه مثلا النهارده ماما عملت لي
قتله بحبها قوي فانا فرحان النهارده واحد
صاحبي قال لي كلمه وحشه قوي فتضايقت لما
الشخص يقعد يكتب كل الحاجات دي هيقدر
يدفنش الحاجات اللي بتفرحه والحاجات اللي
بتزعله
ان انت تطلع الحاجات الصح طلع الحاجات
الغلط
طيب
عاوز اسالكم كم سؤال كده وبرضو نرفع اول
حاجه
زي ما احنا شايفين في ناس قالوا اه في ناس
قالوا لا قال دي حاجه غلط لا طبعا يلا
ناخد مثال تاني
مين فيكم بيحب عصير البرتقان
انا ما بحبوش ايه رايكم ما بحبوش هل ده
معناه ان انتم غلط هل ده معناه ان انا غلط
لا
احنا بشر احنا مختلفين كلنا عندنا سباق
مختلفه نفس حاجه في التولز
مش معنى ان مثلا التولز شخص ممكن تفيدك
ممكن تروح لفاست
طيب انا قاعد بقول الولد سوى الولد عمل
الولد عمل تولز الولد عمل كذا وكذا وكذا
مين الولد ده اصلا
الولد ده يبقى انا
انا
اللي كان باباه مريض السرطان الكبد توفى
سرطان الكبد
اللي مامته كانت بتحارب كل يوم عشان
يتعالج
طيب فاكرين السبت
زي ما بقول لكم
مش لازم انت
افهم نفسك افهم ذاتك هتعرف تسيطر على
المشاعر وهتعرف تكوبلوس فاكرين بتاعت
انا كنت كتبت حته شعر كنت حابب اشاير معكم
بره